so before the video begins i do want to
explain
what you're about to watch a few days
ago i did
a study collaboration with gotham chess
where we tackled eight different
like really interesting positions not
necessarily tactics
but more kind of positional and
intuitive exercises
so i think this will be really
interesting for the viewers to kind of
get a glimpse of
how training works at our level
i also want to thank greg shahadi and
the u.s chess school
for providing the training material
because i know they usually keep it
secretive
so if you want to make a donation to the
uss school
i'll leave a link in the description and
they are a 501c3 so if you want to make
a tax-deductible contribution
you can do so and supports from the top
talent
in the u.s now what you're about to
watch
is the last four positions that we
attempted to solve if you want to see
the first four levy posted on his
channel
i'll leave a link in the video
description and uh
and leave a comment let me know what you
think if you want to see more content
like this
and uh i do encourage viewers to kind of
play along and try and come up with your
own ideas
as we tackle the problems and i hope you
enjoy the video
okay we have um we have four more
let's do it i wanna i wanna scan a few
of these for okay
i don't want any end game ones those are
kind of lame
i wouldn't mind the nine game one but
okay
okay here when you sometimes when you
when you say something is lame
it signifies that you're not comfortable
with it and you need to work at it
to to make it less lame i don't know
okay because i was picking up on some
fear there
okay okay um all right well here's an
endgame position and
uh you know we uh um
yeah i'll face my fears okay
see you in three minutes good all right
good luck
okay um again i'm absorbing what's going
on
equal material um
some balance with the structure bishop
for knight
white has white has a bit more like
activity like small lean development
like rooks out of play
so we might want to act timely in this
position
um beginning to search for candidate
moves
i guess black wants to play this and
activate the rook because it's a
the easiest file to access
so the first move that comes to mind is
rook d1
which prevents rook t tactically because
then bishop b7 wins material
uh if we play rook d1 the knight's a bit
restricted the
king has a hard time coming in
i think yeah just rook t1
[Music]
rook d1 is is just a nice prophylactic
move
if we don't play rook d1 black's gonna
you're just gonna get the rook in
um again i'm looking for
for some reason to reject the move some
response for black
uh knight a6 is is legal
96 we might even sack in the pawn might
be premature
i was thinking rook d7 but
let's think rook d1986
b5 knight c5
there's kind of a funny line actually so
rook d1 knight a6 b5 knight c5
rook goes back to c1 setting up some
discovery
knight can go back to b7
[Music]
oh there's a funnier line so rook d1
knight a6 rook
a1 oh no our pawn oh no black's pawn
oh no our bishop oh no this doesn't work
because knight b8
i was thinking we would skewer an end oh
it doesn't work
okay so rook d1986
it's like the only active move for black
i'm trying to figure out if we want to
sack
how do we want to do this maybe just
rook g7
we give away the pawn and then bishop i
think i got it mr rosen
okay let's let's hear it uh
it's obviously either rook d1 or k1
yeah oh i didn't even consider rookie
one actually
so i i'm so i'm not gonna lie to you
um i'm not saying rook a1
mostly because i think i'm getting too
fancy like i don't see a legitimate
reason to play it
i will say that i saw rook a1 king b8
rook d1 and then that's an improved
version
because obviously after rook d1 rook d8
this should be seven as i'm sure you
pointed out to your chat
we have this nice thing um i calculated
rook a1
a6 rook d1 and
i don't get the difference i guess the
pawn is on a light square which in some
end games can help our bishop
but i'm not going to lie to you eric i
do not i don't get the difference so i'm
just going to go
so i oh you you would play rook d1
immediately
yeah interesting because after hearing
your thought process with like rook a1
provoke a6 move back to d1 um
i kind of liked that better even though
i didn't consider it
okay initially i spent all my time like
thinking
okay rook d1 how does black respond
and i was only looking at rook t1 knight
a6 and trying to just refute knight a6
um because i wanted to
i wanted to have like something concrete
here
where like one of the lines i've
i wanted to make work is then we move
back we lose a pawn we win box palm we
lose our bishop we have rocket but
there's knight b in the end
so that didn't work so i eventually
thought okay rook d1
knight a6 uh and then just
move the rook into d7 give away the pawn
and then kind of just chill like bishop
a4
and then we're guaranteed to try and
clean up on the seventh rank
and just have a more active rook
but with all that stuff i kind of like
rook a1 batter is just an improvement
but actually i'm not sure because rook
a1 black can maybe just gamble the pawn
and
that's what i thought but then we played
b5 b6
that's really funny oh my god i didn't
even see that
knight a6 was legal like i don't know
why i just totally
what what did i i guess i thought
oh i know what i thought i know what i
thought so i thought rook d1
knight a6 b5 knight b4 rook d7 so i
calculated this and i was like this is
winning but i completely forgot
oh the pawn like it's just it's just
that
straightforward and then which now makes
me think it's rook a1 also
yeah it's type of position like we it
seems like white should be better but
white has to play
kind of quickly um to like see some
advantage
before black can kind of get the rook
into play so
i'm i'm still conflicted i've like
intuitively i i still like rook d one
better
but um yeah if this were a longer game i
would take some time debating between
these two moves
oh my god okay
so the right answer is rook a1
but the defensive so the in the game
greg played rook d1
but there's something even more
incredible uh
knight a6 oh knight b8 yeah
it's not it's it's actually not knight
c5 because then this is still soft
because rk1 king b8 b6
wow that's that's actually fascinating i
can see
but i thought knight a6 just didn't work
at all because b5 and then we can go
back
i guess knight c5 or k1 so it's like but
knight oh knight b8 oh wow knight b
also didn't see yeah that's like one of
the moves it's
like you you only look at the forward
moves but the backward move it hits the
bishop and covers g7
[Music]
wow okay i guess like mentally my
my brain just discarded the knight
because it i i just
i was like he can't stomp rook d7 and
the a7 pawn is just always weak but the
knight to b8
knights are so tricky even even deep
into that endgame it's
uh it's important not to discard the
the dumb looking knight moves
that's amazing wow yeah it's rk1
so if we go back just to explain
[Music]
at least you consider rook a1 but rook
a1 it provokes
a6 yeah and then i assume that d1
and that way there's no knight a6
and then we're we're just dominating the
position
and if if knight be five you just go
here yeah just here and like the knight
can't touch us
because it's just totally and then if
rook f8 it's
well you know what's interesting about
this position is that it's actually not
over you now need to bring the king
so if you start getting tunnel vision
and for example play rook b7
trying to win this pawn like black goes
knight back which was not possible
a move ago uh although i guess i guess
you could have theoretically played it
like
here but you would just slowly improve
your position
black is just seems stuck here actually
because it looks always tied down the
king can't really
do much neither can the knight yeah
rookie one that's actually interesting
yeah i
i thought about it but i completely
didn't realize why
like what is black's in the knight a69b
and i
i didn't have like at all but i guess
i'll say this if we had 10 minutes if
this was classical i think we find rook
a1 knight a6 knight b and all this stuff
but definitely in two and a half minutes
that's hard yeah it was like
concrete calculation and understanding
the nuance of forcing flak to play a6
yeah that was a good one that was
probably one of the more difficult ones
just to
like see thoroughly some hidden ideas
there
white to move again yes
all right i'll see you in three
okay good luck okay so
just making sure this is white to move
okay equal material
seems like some actually this looks like
a benoni uh or not
greenfield greg was probably black
um
[Music]
again just absorbing what's going on
a white seems to have some pressure like
just better pieces
blocks a bit lacking in harmony
uh z9 and h4 is a bit strange we
probably want it to come
back at some point
one move that comes to mind is d6 but
the only only probably helps black
so yeah it's easy just to just stare at
this position
not know what to think about um
i mean in terms of ways we can improve
i don't think we want to take the pawn
because in rook c8
and our uh our thing gets pinned
i'm really not sure bishop g5
bishop f3
d6 looks interesting though just from uh
just like we have a past pawn why not
push it bishop e6 queen b5
because we do prevent the knight from i
guess we give away the c6 square so
there's this move but the lights kind of
tied down
no we don't want to push the pawn juice
oops ah
what did i do okay we're not playing
queen f4
in tricky position if we move back
i guess we give the bishop a square
wow it's already time i have no idea
what i would do
maybe eighth a3
i have no idea alexa quiet
i'm gonna wait live wait for levy to to
start talking
i'm still looking here
i'm not sure if if this were a bullet
game i'd play like rook c-1 and
uh
and just like gradually improve i guess
what does black want to do
black is a bit stuck actually
yeah we're going overtime here levy
might be stuck too
there's might be five as well
oh knight b5
and then if we trade we're also
threatening knight d6
not super confident but knight b5
is looking like a nice option
[Music]
out of everything considered so far
because we're threatening knight d6
we don't mind if the bishop oh 95 takes
takes
knight d5 bishop c4
even bishop three looks nice okay uh
we're way over time yo
i think we went over time there yeah i
mean i i was sitting here just
like really contemplating life who
started the uh
last analysis was it you or me me
uh i think you started yeah because you
were mentioning
one okay so i've i struggled with this
one
i um yes my i set a timer and it went
off and i
had no no clue what i was gonna do okay
um
and then but then like i kept
thinking because you were still thinking
too so
um in terms of the position i mean
one of the early moves i looked at was
d6
yeah which oh play that uh you could go
to the board yeah d6 um which
it's a move to consider i think it just
gives away too many squares mainly e6
for the bishop
or the eventual uh or even c6
um some cases in like reroute so
intuitively even though it looks
interesting i don't think i'd want to
play it so soon
uh another thought was just to move the
knight back to f3
but then i realized like the purpose of
the nylon h4 and what probably happened
earlier in the game
was it it moved here to kick away the
bishop
yeah and like black's in a situation
where the bishop
is just a bit awkward on d7 it can't
develop actively to these squares
it's restricted along both diagonals so
we don't want to give the bishop
like an easy square to move to um
when my timer went off i was like i kind
of just panicked and thought okay i'll
just play rook c1 and improve
uh but then as more time passed i i
found another candidate move
which would probably be my choice uh is
knight b5
okay which even though it does allow the
potential trade
i think the resulting position where we
get the bishop hair
there's a lot of pressure on the queen
side looks nice for white
knight b5 also threatens knight d6
um so it looks like a nice move to start
trying to squeeze black
in some way okay i'm not entirely
confident
i can confidently say that this one goes
to team gotham but it's gonna end up in
your portion of the youtube video
oh no my content rookie
4 oh rookie 4 is
as a move i forgot about which is why b5
is the
is the really scary problem here for
black ah
so a4 well here's the thing
so yeah i so like i saw this and i'm
like it doesn't work
because and then i'm like oh my god
there's this move which is just such a
peculiar move
yeah it's actually it's it's probably a
typical type of move for these
structures
yeah it's still like kind of a blind
spot
you don't always consider the rook
delving into your territory
uh basically i spent the entire time
deliberating between bishop f3 and a4
like i
[Music]
i even now i don't actually fully know
basically all i calculated was um like
if a4
knight b form bishop c5
and like knight c2 that doesn't work
obviously so i was like okay if a4 they
will play rook c8 to enable knight b4
[Music]
but i i
even now i can't tell the difference
between these two moves part of me wants
to play bishop f3
because a4 is so committal like maybe i
want to play a3 and don't allow knight
before at all
but that allows black a full tempo and
maybe there's something i'm missing like
i don't know queen a5 or something like
now that i'm
talking out loud you're definitely on a
better track than me
like not not plundering or nice well
i no that's it i mean it just spotted it
i guess in the
the first like thought that i had
basically was b5 and and i'm like it
doesn't work and like oh my god rookie
four so
i actually said out loud i was like no
no one tell eric rookie for exists
i was looking at the chat so uh even
yeah
these goons were looking at you know
queen c5 so um
uh that's all you have to know about
much i think your chat is probably on
average like 800 points higher rated
than my chat
uh and queen a6 very creative ways of
losing the queen
zero compensation it's interesting
sometimes to look for the worst move in
the position
some some chat members are good at that
i i didn't quite like bishop f3 it was
on my radar just as an improving move
but
it takes away the last square for our
knight i mean
black can't win the knights but um
it just looked a little bit awkward
so h6 perhaps these don't actually have
written answers so we actually have to
boot up the the trusty
engine the trusty machine i i don't have
access to engine on this analysis board
so
oh i might actually switch to my borah
just to just to see the lines
um
engine says knight back to f3
knight f3
but like i'm leaving it running knight
f3 it's still the top
choice what is this
oops rook takes e3
rookie 3 is a top line so why not
bishop let's say bishop g4 just typical
move
i i i guess white is just the position
h3
okay well i can conveniently i can
convincingly say it's not knight v5
but i also was like why would i play
knight f3 i feel like we just came from
this position
so yeah why
you know it feels like this just
happened
but we don't know that like it could
yeah it could have been something
earlier
okay so let's okay knight b5 just to
confirm
loses for e4
so you were suggesting i mean a4 is one
of the top moves
but night wait night before what night
before bishop c5
a5
what sucks upon oh my god sex oh my it's
it's
it's crazier than that eric bishop
before rook c8
what queen b3 queen b3 a before queen b4
rook c3 and then rookie okay
um
oh man that's hard to calculate
i wonder if this one wasn't like it was
included as
a pr like it wasn't checked with the
engine
and maybe the intended solution was like
a move like a4
not realizing this computer line
that that's wild
yeah well it's it's actually more
fascinating to me that rook takes e3
is just the that's also crazy yeah
like just
just take and then go here and hope for
the best
and white's best option is to sack back
the exchange
and get this switching to your board
wait how did that happen oh wow
so we just play e4 maintain the center
yeah yeah i didn't see any of that
i'm not gonna lie uh i definitely didn't
see that either
um okay
so i was looking at bishop f3
but computer's not too impressed it just
says
spitzel either rook b8 or rookie
5 or even still rookie 3.
amazing you definitely deserve more
credit for this one though because you
you identified rookie four you didn't
find all the crazy engine lines though
no no no no most certainly not um
yeah wow that is wild it's funny this
was the one i was like incredibly
confident on and then
just you get this cold shower um okay
but we have two more we have two more we
should
not sit here and you know stare at uh at
the board we should i i went back to
ones that have annotations so they've
probably been engine verified
okay um that was good that one was wild
this this next position is also pretty
wild though
so it's white to move
yes yes
yes
okay uh three minutes yup
see you in uh at 48. cool
okay that was accidental confetti
there's a keyboard shortcut
uh when i do control b i did ctrl v
and then miss typed control
[Music]
b it's a browser extension anyway
um let me focus white to move
okay so we have the bishops it's equal
material
um i mean c5 is a move we would love to
achieve
it doesn't quite does it work tactically
actually
because if knight c5 we have queen d4
winning material
i think the problem is
knight takes d5
and we have nothing
because knight f6 comes well the thing
is black's not even threatening this
because of queen d4 so i wonder if we
can prepare
c5 with a move i guess black wants to
play rook c8 here
oh but the a pawn hangs
also black is threatening this pawn
so that's more more reason to play
knight e3
which just looks like a really natural
move reinforcing the pawn
also over defending d5 so we're
threatening c5
and just to reiterate if c5 takes queen
d4
and that's the main threat and if black
doesn't take then we get c6 with a fork
so knight e3 um
i guess the question how does black
respond to this because there's not
quite rook c8
queen e7 i think just runs into knights
f5
another double attack if queen c5 bishop
d4
looks really nice yeah this just looks
like an all-around
great move very multi-purpose
like these three squares are the most
relevant
uh one more time rook c8 rook a5
i guess the nice thing is if knight
takes
oh wait 93 rook
actually this would require some
calculation
[Music]
it doesn't dissuade me from playing
knight e3 it might just be a bit more
complicated
i didn't really consider like the other
like there's a made in one threats
um which i probably should have
considered
queen g3 i think there's queen h4
hitting the pawn queen can then sit here
so with this move we do prevent we do
kind of discourage queen h4
okay um i think it's time
okay i forgot to set a timer but i think
we're we're
timed yes um
all right i gotta go first uh
i have nothing conclusive so i
um i obviously looked at c5
and then after knight d5 i just like i
don't know i didn't find a way to brute
force anything
um i looked at d6 and my idea with d6 is
that
i'm pushing a pawn and that looks scary
and i also thought maybe rookie seven
because i don't know why but that kind
of looks scary also i guess i can play
c5
is sort of the point but i
don't fully believe in the move d6 which
brought me to queen d3 which attacks h7
but i thought f5 was just really good
like i just thought
the fact that black gets to take space
like g6 is one thing but f5 is
i don't know i mean f5 just i just
somehow don't believe
which then brought me to queen d4
but i was not able to refute queen f6
fully um
but now that i'm looking at it maybe i
just take and then go rookie seven
but i'm not gonna pretend like i you
know i had that prior
um so then i looked at a night move
like knight e3 knight g3 i even looked
at f4 to stop queen g5
i scanned everything uh i'm mostly just
stalling for time at this point so if
you have to
force me to play a move then i will
probably play
i'll probably play queen d3 okay and
then i will figure it out
interesting so i i spent most of my time
just looking at
one move i will say i started with
like the same kind of forcing
calculations e5 my d5
quickly realized it doesn't lead to much
um i actually i didn't
i i've like after i saw c5 didn't work
i started looking at knight e3 more i
looked at it the more i really liked it
and then only at the very end did i even
consider queen d3
and then just saw i saw the response
queen
h4 rather than than f5
which maybe also just diffuses white's
attack many cases the queen can sit here
or
black might be threatening this rookie
four
um rook e4
queen and you survived that oh my god
bishop c1 i guess yeah i guess
yeah no yeah wow
but f5 might be a another like maybe
just more
simple just block the diagonal
for the the battery but
yeah like i looked at knight e3 and i
did not refute it but i i i don't know
so i i really like 93 because it's very
multi-purpose move where uh
first of all we over defend e5
so if we get another move in knight e3
and then c5 is just winning um
because d5 can't be taken if knight
takes c5 we have queen d4 with a double
attack
uh we also defend c4 so we're preventing
knight takes e4
we're also having the ideas of knight f5
which can be relevant in cases like if
black tries queen h4
um but then there's other cases where
uh where like we combined queen d3 or
queen d4 and out of five
and then like one line that looked a
little bit
weird was knight knight e3 black has to
stop c5
so there's rook c8
and we can we could consider snagging
the pawn
but then have to deal with these lines
where rook gets attacked
so i was thinking there would be enough
resources for white between
either either going into that line and
um
including a move like queen d4 or just
going straight for the kill of knight f5
so i basically just concluded 93 is the
most most like useful multi-purpose move
oh my god
this is stuff this position is black to
move oh no
but but we did it you know let's uh
still analyze yeah yeah yeah should we
use the engine then
queen d3 and 93 are both good
[Laughter]
oh my god it's like plus four for white
so but but you know you know i will say
i will say uh
queen d3 g6 uh wait what's wrong with f5
okay so it's actually a combination of
both of our ideas
it's like queen d3 and then you you need
to go knight e3 so it's just that white
is
it's actually crazy if it was white to
move it's plus five
really yeah multiple lines too
that is astounding so white's attack is
just extremely strong
wow
and then okay so it's funny because if
you flip it in the original position
should we take more time to well no
because i saw the answer uh
okay because i i but the answer for
black is actually knight takes c4
oh yeah i just assumed that was one of
the threats and then wha but
queen d3 queen h4 oh
okay it's what you said it's this
geometric sequence which holds
defend from a distance yeah queen h4 g3
on knight two hitting the queen yeah
yeah that was relevant in the other line
too
all right well that was uh you know uh
good
um see the thing is i didn't look at the
moves because i didn't want to spoil the
answer
so uh okay this next one i will
yeah we just got used to every position
being white to move
but then the other thing like we still
got value from like
looking at whatever these positions are
even though that one we kind of botched
like we got our kind of calculation and
ideas
flowing and we're treating every
position as just like
what to do like not not looking for
immediate tactics just trying to find
the best move
i yeah i'm glad that i just checked for
this next one because this next one is
black to move
okay uh okay one sec
uh but yeah i mean obviously there's
you know there's value um
granted it is it is good to solve
positions for the
for the right person it's always my
favorite thing when i was teaching
uh my student would sit there for five
minutes and then go wait whose move is
it and i was like i know man tell me
about it
okay three minutes
9 p.m for you 8 pm for me yes
good luck all right good luck okay
uh huge thank you to uh are we supposed
to thanks danny
welcome back good to see you gifting 50
subs that's insane
also we're at like an all-time high sub
number
of 4 000 subs but i should okay i should
use my time appropriately here
um this is supposed to be a serious
training session
uh so it's wait it's white to mover
wait it's black to move right it's black
to move
black to move okay
he just told the story about his
students like thinking in position
asking which color to move okay so first
one that comes to mind is
is knight takes d4 now it takes v4 i
mean this is a very common tactical
motif
uh the one thing we have to be aware of
is bishop takes h7
king h8 it's kind of messy
it looks nice for black though
also thinking like if we can mix up the
move order like start with this
and then take and then we go down a
piece
probably not enough compensation there
okay so
and this is still an idea though like
queen h4 g3 queen h3 but then knight f4
it's almost really good if not for
knight f4
and black would have a promising
position because f3 would be weak
but it gives me more reason to lean
towards this move knight d4
and then i mean we are trading pawns one
way or another
bishop takes h7 king h8
but i like the transformation for black
uh there's another line takes
and it seems very concrete so takes
takes king h8
white does have a few options with
moving the queen
too
[Music]
oh but if if white moves the queen there
there's uh there's 92
i think some eventual queen h4
it just looks too too good for white
um so knight d4 what was white doing
here
so he takes bishop h7 king h8
um i mean white probably takes back
queen here
g3 queen takes there's some bishop move
back
but f3 is so weak
no offense to f3 maybe bishop bishop e4
d5
yeah this looks this looks pretty
straightforward just a common
alexa quiet yo
um so i'm conflicted
okay uh wait did i start last time
uh i yes you did
okay so you you but you you you drew me
in there with
your conflict i'm curious but uh
i'm not too conflicted so
i really i really want to go bishop
takes f3
oh i didn't consider that
i don't understand this position
actually i mean it isn't
it just okay so i i spent most of my
time just spotting
this move and thinking this is just
really nice for black
um oh wait uh go to my board
sorry yeah uh that takes d4
idea knight takes e4 queen h4 queen f2
oh no dude
i also i also saw this i was like queen
h4 and then i oh my gosh
yay mutual blind spot i i swear i saw
the exact same thing like literally
i was like what is this but you realize
you realize sooner
before it was yeah yeah
queen f2 is uh yeah it's a blind spot
because you
you forget the queen can legally move
here when the knight's not no longer yes
yes i still want to make this work like
takes takes bishop c5
i know i uh
but queen edge h4 check immediately is
probably just winning right i mean i
don't know
i was considering that too so i i
rejected this because of g3
and then bishop e4 oh wait what
okay wait queen h4 g3 yeah queen h3
knight f4
was why i rejected it
but maybe we just moved back and it's
like positionally weak for white
oh interesting so actually bishop e4 but
that's probably
hmm that allows queen g2 so
wait in what line bishop g3
i think knight f4 is an issue
our queen is kind of short on squares
there and it's bishop takes f3 right
that's interesting i i don't i don't
know
i mean now now that i i see
queen f2 refutes knight takes d4 i i
still i'm
i'm drawn to queen h4 g3 queen f6 but
um tell me about bishop about three like
what's your calculation
actually i just i just realized i might
be like a complete idiot um
because bishop f3 there could be bishop
f5
which i didn't even i didn't even
consider for a second move
yeah i i well i like this this this and
i just thought
ah like we get here
and this channel is definitely your
style of play like just
sack and attack yeah there's uh two
types of sacrifices
uh you know proper ones mikhail talls
and
uh i'm not included in this category um
i i like this seems very professional
soften it up and then yeah these uh f3
and d4
are quite both tender
yeah if i was in a blitz game i would
probably play bishop takes f3 and lose
but but
this this and just going back seems very
very controlled
this just seems
because how do you guard this is there
like a3
but then f3 is hanging but actually like
a3
takes don't know something takes pawn
takes
here and like this white castles
white is not legally i don't have to
we're gonna assume castling is legal
yeah uh i was wondering instead of
taking on c3 if we can
we can start with some in between moves
like knight d4
[Music]
just a possibility but
i mean here we we went upon if castling
can we just keep our pond advantage
somehow either like take the night
or maybe just keep our bishop along the
long diagonal like move all the way back
but then there might be like g4
oh queen g6 is risky looking
but maybe necessary
why aren't i want to get the knight to
h3 in that position
take some work
yeah wow huh
okay let's let's look
let's look yeah go for it
uh it is a hundred percent queen h4 and
then uh
so the engine eval might not work
because it doesn't
realize that castling is legal oh
which is i don't even know how to set
that up
how do i like
can i even enable that
uh that's so strange i might you could
if you wanted to just paste in the pgn
now because you have the annotated
file if you know how to do that
i think i should be able to yeah one sec
okay yeah so queen h4 queen f6
but how bad is this
take knight h4 well of course the
computer just refutes me by
voluntarily playing the move king d1
yes see like i would definitely lose
against computers at all times um
also castling actually um
yeah i i forgot about castling that
admittedly did not occur to me
uh all right and just as a as a
castle not f3 rook f3 and like bishop
oh bishop oh ouch
yeah okay um
this one i was too stubborn i mean queen
is four
you deserve more points so because it's
bishop three is better than just
blundering a piece
wait wait wait wait oh oh oh oh yeah
yeah queen f6 yeah just going back
uh a3
oh so it's interesting if you take this
is wrong because after bishop f3 castles
white is better oh
so i guess yeah that file is a problem
yeah
oh yeah just g4 and like h3 yeah and
you're just pinned everywhere oh my god
i was thinking about this line like
trying to figure out how to evaluate
because there's uh there's a double pin
light's pinned but the g pawns pin the
black is more stuck can you choose
probably a threat
i i'm happy that in my you know
this is this is the beautiful thing
about my style sometimes you you look at
bishop of three and it's idiotic and
then sometimes you see like g4
and you're like this must be good and
and the computer agrees but
um apparently after queen f6 a3 black
should play
it doesn't actually
it doesn't actually say uh i don't have
the engine turned on but
um it says this
castle ah
it's a move order thing
so you you you don't take you you you go
here
attacking the rook first
so that if you have one then you take
and then you go back
i'm trying to follow along can you can
you share that one more time
so instead of instead of taking on c3 we
we take on f3
hitting the rook and if castling
what happens if castles the knight takes
d4
oh
ah so we we simultaneously defend the
bishop
attack the queen and if takes we we keep
the tempo
so then we're not losing our bishop
we just have to master the tempo is the
key to success
yeah that's one thing that i i try to
practice at least a few times a day
because um
it's definitely the thing that's lacking
in my skill set the most
magnus should try to master the tempo i
think it'll it'll really serve him
well in his next world championship
match i feel like he's
he's moved on from mastering the tempo
and he's just mastering
more meaningful things in life these
days like gambit
like collabing with ludwig and
gambiting yeah and bon cloud and nfts
yes like there's so many more things to
life than just a tempo
like understanding the soul of the
father exactly